there's this one food that you need to
be aware of that has the potential to
completely nullify
any help
from the top three nutrients in
supporting your immune system i'm
talking about
vitamin d help i'm talking about vitamin
c help and zinc help these three
nutrients are the nutrients that most
people take when they're coming down
with some type of infection so they're
very very important in helping your
immune system
i'm going to tell you the one food that
can cause a deficiency in all three of
these nutrients and
negatively affect your immune system
your immune system is dependent on these
three nutrients so let's first talk
about vitamin d is vitamin important
with your immune system
uh yes it's involved with every single
part of your immune system your t cells
your b cells your phagocytes the
neutrophils every single part of your
immune system has vitamin d receptors
and when someone has an inflammatory
condition called the cytokine storm
vitamin d is essential in keeping that
inflammation
regulated so vitamin d helps modulate or
regulate the immune system vitamin d
also minimizes the collateral damage
from pathogens especially viruses so
without vitamin d
you have a much longer infection
and you have a lot of other
complications all right the next one is
vitamin c right you know vitamin c is
important probably at the first sign of
a cold you might take vitamin c what
does vitamin c do to the immune system
well number one it increases the
mobility of white blood cells it makes
them more active and without vitamin c
they're very sluggish vitamin c also
increases something called phagocytosis
that's the ability of phagocytes to eat
up
pathogens vitamin c also helps the white
blood cells
produce their weaponry to defend against
infections and without vitamin c
the duration of your illness extends a
lot longer than it should even if you
took the amount of vitamin c in your
blood and compared it to the vitamin c
in the white blood cell the vitamin c in
the white blood cell is a hundred times
more than in the blood why because your
immune system is dependent on vitamin c
all right now what about the trace
mineral zinc is that important
it's very very important in fact
without zinc
your thymus gland the gland that
trains your
t cells it's like a training camp for t
cells
atrophies it shrinks zinc is vitally
important not just with the thymus gland
but for all the lymphatic tissue the
lymph nodes in general without zinc
you're not going to have the quantity of
white blood cells and without zinc the
duration of infection goes on and on and
on when people suffer from a lot of
symptoms from
interaction with a virus for example and
they have all these complications it's
really the immune reaction towards the
pathogen that's creating the damage
more than the pathogen itself and it's
these three nutrients that minimize the
collateral damage so
if you want to go through an infection
with minimal symptoms these three
nutrients are crucial all right so what
is the food that we need to avoid
if you guessed sugar you are correct now
let's just take first vitamin c the
chemistry of vitamin c is very very
similar
to sugar okay
if you're consuming
sugar and vitamin c at the same time the
body will always
take on the sugar before vitamin c
leaving you high and dry or deficient of
vitamin c diabetics that have this
sustained blood sugar nearly always have
a vitamin c deficiency and when you're
deficient in vitamin c another symptom
you might get is bleeding gums fatigue
collagen
problems
but mainly it's going to be a weakened
immune system all right what about
vitamin d
well when you're consuming sugar
the absorption of vitamin d goes way
down
sugar
also impairs the activation
of vitamin d so if you go from inactive
vitamin d to active vitamin d you need
help from your kidney but sugar gets in
the way of that sugar interferes with
that activation of vitamin d
and the third thing that sugar does to
vitamin d is it stops the synthesis or
production of vitamin d you can't really
produce vitamin d if there's too much
sugar in the body this is why diabetics
are nearly always low in vitamin d and
if you consume a lot of sugar
that turns into
liver fat
and that also can inhibit the activation
and absorption of vitamin d from another
angle all right now let's talk about
zinc
sugar
causes
excessive amount of zinc to be excreted
from your kidneys and that's called
hyper zinguria
too much zinc in the urine that comes
from too much sugar
sugar also impairs the absorption of
zinc so this is another reason why
people that are diabetics are nearly
always deficient in zinc zinc is also
really important in supporting
the beta cell and the pancreas the cell
that makes insulin that then regulates
blood sugars and that does the same with
vitamin d as well vitamin d is very very
important in
protecting you against developing
diabetes so not only does sugar deplete
vitamin d but low vitamin d
can activate or increase your risk of
getting diabetes now when i'm talking
about sugar i'm not just talking about
sugar i'm talking about other things
that turn into sugar pretty quickly like
refined carbohydrates
refined carbohydrates like in grains are
also loaded with phytates which then can
also block
zinc
so as you can see when you're doing too
many carbs
too many sugars your immune system is
going to greatly suffer all right so
where do you get vitamin c
the best source is sauerkraut okay
sauerkraut per cup if you get a really
good blend of sauerkraut that's maybe
from the healthy store or the farmer's
market or you make it yourself
per cup it's about 700 milligrams now
the rda is only 70. so we're getting
700 10 times more than the rda so that's
why you want to have sauerkraut to get
your vitamin c or you can get it from
bell peppers and you can get it from
leafy greens all right vitamin d
difficult to get it from
foods you want to get it from the sun
um if it's winter time then take it as a
supplement but like i said before
vitamin d and zinc are really really
important
if you're a diabetic or you're trying to
repair the damage from being a diabetic
and as far as zinc goes zinc is high in
red meat it's also high in shellfish
and seafood
now there's just one last thing i want
to tell you something else that can
paralyze
your immune system that is not food in
its stress
cortisol
from stress
paralyzes your immune system so the two
worst things for your immune system is
stress
and sugar on that note
i want to show you a video how you can
make your own vitamin d supplements
check it out i put it right here